my friends we have to remember his  repeated lessons of history the price of  freedom is still and always will be  eternal vigilance freedom demands more  care and devotion than any other system  and whatever's happened in his led us to  this place today we've done that  together and we want you to know we  remember that and we're proud of you  grateful to know you  hell style offers more than exposure to  great ideas and wonderful classes it  offers an incredible community that will  support you along the way  Kirby center in Hillsdale College is  helping guide us back to that journey to  who we are what we stand for and what  made this country so exceptional in the  first place